you
hey Vsauce Michael here do you have a
best friend who is there for you 24/7
365 sorry that's not really good enough
if you're a friend truly had your back
they would be there for you 24 point
zero zero zero zero zero zero six seven
three sixty five point two four two one
eight nine one also George Washington
was born on February 22nd 1732 at least
that's what we're told
however his family Bible says he was
born on February 11th 1730 1/2 so which
is it mister I cannot tell a lie
oh and don't even ask about 1752 in
Russia
17:52 looked pretty normal but check out
what the British Empire was up to that
year nothing really out of the ordinary
except ember the second was followed by
the 14th were eleven days just deleted
where'd they go what happened then it is
time to question time and how the earth
moves reconciling both of these things
has led to some pretty strange things we
all love time-lapse videos of the stars
moving across the sky but really we are
the ones who are
tumbling through the universe on a giant
wet rock vehicle called earth with a
windshield called the sky as viewed from
above the North Pole we spin
counterclockwise west chases east
I always remember this by thinking of
the US as a weird Mane headed animal
with Texas and Florida legs running
forward but we don't just spin
we also revolve around the Sun on a
plane tilted 23.4 degrees relative to
our spin it's kind of nauseating at this
scale but from this perspective you can
see that the Sun rising and setting is
just the earth pointing you towards and
then away from the Sun this motion
causes your sunrise your noon the moment
when the Sun is highest in your sky
before your Sun set to more closely
investigate this movement let's talk
about meridians you are on one at this
very moment your meridian is just
aligned from where you are right now
straight towards the North and South
Poles it's a line of longitude as
opposed to the horizontal lines that lay
flat when north or south is up that we
call flat attune or actually latitude
the Sun is highest in the sky to you
your noon when your Meridian is pointed
right at the Sun a cool thing happens at
this moment all shadows around you point
directly towards one of Earth's poles
unless you're on the sub solar point
the subsolar point is the point on
Earth's surface directly below the Sun
it's always somewhere you can check its
current location online links as always
in the description on the subsolar point
shadows fall straight down so they can
easily disappear twice a year the
subsolar point crosses over Hawaii the
only place in the US where it hits land
and when it does it is called Lahaina
noon meaning cool Sun straight vertical
objects look unnatural during this brief
time like they don't belong as if they
were photoshopped in without regard for
reality in Honolulu a sculpture by Isamu
Noguchi called sky gate casts a twisted
shadow all day every day except during
Lahaina noon when its shadow is a
perfect circle you may not live in a
place where the Sun ever appears
directly overhead but once every Earth
rotation the subsolar point falls
somewhere on your Meridian making it
noon for you the technical name for this
noon for you is local apparent solar
noon the clock on your wrist and the
clock on your phone don't tell you your
local apparent solar time because long
ago we realized that if every meridian
had its own time a person just a few
kilometers away seeing different shadows
than you did would disagree with you on
what time it was so town's adopted their
own time now later on this trick was
standardized and time zones as we know
them today came about but that's not all
we didn't like about shadow based
sundial time to explore deeper we have
to begin by asking what's a day
I mean obviously it's just the time it
takes the earth to turn around once
right but according to what everything
else in space is moving in some way to
the universe doesn't include a
convenient sheet of graph paper at
Absolute rest we can trace paths on the
best we can do on that front is to look
at very very far far far away stars so
far away like distant features of the
landscape out the window of a moving car
they barely move as Earth does now to
them a Meridian on earth completes a
trip around about once every twenty
three point nine hours this is called a
side aerial day side aerial means
pertaining to the Stars even though the
sidereal day seems pretty clear it's not
what our calendars and clocks are based
on because there's a nearer star whose
position relative to us has a bigger
effect on our lives the Sun looking down
on the north pole at Earth's
counterclockwise spin the earth also
moves counterclockwise around the Sun
after a sidereal day the earth has moved
a bit along its orbit so some more
rotation is required for the same
meridian to point back towards the Sun
again this longer definition of one
rotation is what the modern calendar and
clock is based on it is called the solar
day but here's the thing exactly how
long the earth has to rotate to complete
a solar day changes day to day our
clocks are just based on the average
amount of time this takes so throughout
the year they fall ahead and behind the
Sun this is a solar graph a picture of
the sun's path across the sky every
single day if our clocks actually told
us local apparent solar time if you took
a picture of the sky every day at noon
you should get a line of Suns but this
is what really happens
over the course of a year it will appear
as though your clock is running slow and
then fast and then slow again and then
fast again this problem was known since
at least ancient times even if its cause
was it in order to reconcile the two the
equation of time was constructed in this
sense equation means to reconcile the
equation of time was applied to what a
clock said in order to compute the real
time the solar time a sundial would show
now some fancy clocks called equation
clocks were made that would do this for
you but eventually we gave up we gave up
and just said no the real time isn't
what the Sun says it's what our
inventions say now this transition was a
big one it was humanity growing up it
was like the first time you realize
you're stronger than your parents we
realized our timepieces were more
regular and turned our backs on the
timepieces nature had but what causes
this disagreement in the first place
as it turns out the answer revolves
around revolving the way the Earth
revolves around the Sun if the Equator
faced the Sun all the time and the earth
always orbited at the same speed the
subsolar point would just stay right
there on the equator throughout the year
and the amount of extra time spent
rotating the earth needed to do to
finish a solar day would always be the
same but those two things aren't the
case first of all the Earth's orbit is
slightly elliptical so its speed varies
throughout the year when it's moving
around the Sun faster around the
beginning of January the amount of extra
turning time needed to complete the
solar day is longer than when it's
further away from the Sun and moving
more slowly there's more because the
earth is tilted the subsolar point is
dragged throughout the year in a circle
around Earth that's not the equator so
it changes directly
moving northeast then leveling out and
going southeast before leveling out and
going northeast again during times of
the year when the subsolar point is
being dragged by Earth's orbit mostly
east it gains against Earth's spin
faster more time is required for the day
to finish now by coincidence we are
alive at a time when both of these
phenomena lengthen and shorten days at
roughly the same time so they add up
making September 18th almost a minute
shorter than the longest day of the year
December 22nd for northern hemisphere
Ian's December has the shortest periods
of daylight but the whole solar day from
sunrise to sunrise is for everyone on
earth the longest of the year on
December 22nd people in the North just
spent most of it in darkness earth's
tilt it doesn't just affect how long a
day is it also affects how long a year
is this is because the Earth's tilt is
what causes the seasons for the half of
the earth tilted towards the Sun the
same amount of solar radiation is spread
across less space than it is on the
other half so there is more heat energy
laid down per area this causes what we
call summer and winter for the other
half the amount of time from one of
these seasonal orientations of the earth
to its occurrence again is called a
solar year or a tropical year it's a
very useful way to define a year because
it contains every single season exactly
since it's based on the very
orientations that caused them
but the problem is this the number of
solar days that occur in a solar year is
not a whole number
it's almost 365 but after that many
solar days about 1/4 of a day more
happens before the solar year starts
again this makes designing a calendar
more like designing a calendar if your
calendar only ever has 365 days in a
year over time those dates will drift
from the seasonal positions they used to
occur during unless hmm
this extra quarter of a turn adds up to
a full day after four years see March
1st is coming a day too soon now so if
we just delay March by adding an extra
day at the end of February every four
years a leap day we're back on track
leap days do not add days to your life
you're still going to live the same
number of them they just change what we
call them but really who cares about
being one day earlier every four years I
mean one day isn't much you hardly
notice it but over time
well if America's founders had declared
not only independence from Britain but
also from leap days and abolished them
from happening today 240 years later
their calendar would be a full two
months ahead of Earth's position putting
America's coldest winter days in April
and its hottest summer days in October
adding a day every four years is what
the famous Julian calendar does
introduced in 46 BC by Julius Caesar
it was the defacto standardized Western
calendar for a very long time more than
a millennium but it's not perfect
look closely
leap days actually move the calendar
just slightly too far each time because
I lied 365 and a quarter solar days
don't occur within one solar year the
real number is slightly less and
fluctuates year-to-year based on
long-term changes to earth and the sun's
movements which means adding one day
every four years is just a teensy weensy
too many by 1582 julian calendar dates
were ten days behind the seasons
compared to where they used to be that's
not bad
ten days and more than a millennium and
a half but the Catholic Church cared
because they wanted Easter to occur
exactly when it used to centuries ago
astronomers at the time realized that if
leap days pushed the calendar too far
behind the seasons we would just need to
celebrate fewer of them to fix the
problem specifically we would need three
fewer leap days every four centuries the
rule they wrote to achieve this stated
that every four years would continue to
be a leap year except if it was
divisible by 100 unless it was also
evenly divisible by 400 this removes
three every 400 years on October 4th
Pope Gregory the 13th introduced this
new calendar it took his name the
Gregorian calendar
he also undid the drift that had
occurred since the early days of the
Julian and declared on October 4th that
tomorrow would be October 15th
October 5th to the 14th never happened
in 1582 in countries that listened to
the Pope it took the rest of the world
centuries to hop on board England and
its colonies like the soon-to-be United
States of America adopted the Gregorian
in September of 1750 - by which point
their Julian dates were off from the
seasons by 11 days hence the
disappearing of the 3rd through 13th
when adopted the 1st of the year was
also moved from March to January first
this explains why George Washington's
birthday has two answers although more
closely hitched to the seasons than the
Julian the Gregorian calendar still
isn't perfect its difference causes
dates to become one day off from the
seasons every 3,000 216 years other
calendars have been proposed like the
one stand-up maths calculated that
drifts off even more slowly his video is
a great watch by the way but enough of
all of this let's sit back and enjoy
Earth's movement without trying to
divide it up and name it as a caveat
keep in mind that Earth's oceans and
liquid insides and other celestial
bodies are always pulling and tugging
and sloshing around minutely changing
Earth's movements their effect is
measurable but difficult to notice at
big scales and also don't look like much
in the short term short like the length
of a human life looking from above the
North Pole the equator spin
counterclockwise at about sixteen
seventy kilometers per hour relative to
the Sun Earth orbits counterclockwise at
one hundred and eight thousand
kilometers per hour along a path tilted
23.4 degrees to it's spin within our
local neighborhood of stars our entire
solar system is drifting seventy
thousand kilometers per hour roughly in
the direction of the bright star Vega in
the constellation of Lyra and our solar
system is part of a giant galaxy called
the Milky Way on a plane tilted about
sixty degrees approximately like the
windshield of a car looking from above
Earth's North Pole our entire solar
system races clockwise around the
galactic center at about seven hundred
and ninety two thousand km/h our whole
galaxy is also moving through the
universe we know this because when the
universe was very young it was so hot
electrons and protons jumped around and
photons of light scattered constantly
they couldn't travel very far before
scattering again so the universe was
opaque
but then around 380,000 years after the
Big Bang the universe cooled just enough
for electrons and protons to form
hydrogen suddenly abruptly photons
decoupled from this obstacle course and
could travel relatively unencumbered the
universe became transparent to light
since that moment those early photons
have been propagating through space
every day
ancient photons that last scattered off
this opaque fog at the moment of
decoupling a light date further from
Earth currently is reach us they are
part of the cosmic microwave background
radiation it is visible in every
direction microwave because although
they used to be more energetic the
universe's expansion has redshifted them
now some parts of this radiation are
more redshifted than others because of
our own movement through the universe
controlling for the movements we've
already talked about relative to this
infinite cooling baby picture of the
universe the first and oldest detectable
light we are headed riding along in the
Milky Way in the direction that the
constellations of Leo and Virgo are to
us at a speed of 2.1 million kilometers
per hour towards a thing we don't fully
understand yet simply called the Great
Attractor this is how you on Earth's
surface are moving through the
universe aboard Spaceship Earth okay now
stop this is roughly 100 years of
Earth's movement through space this path
we trace for where we began here is the
path you will take through the universe
in your lifetime you didn't buy a ticket
for this ride your parents signed you up
without asking but nonetheless it is
quite literally the ride of your life
and as always thanks for watching
it is now time for a major Vsauce
announcement you know how for the last
couple of years we've released a holiday
box
well introducing the curiosity box by
Vsauce we created this thing as a
quarterly box this comes to you four
times a year and it comes packed with
amazing exclusive Vsauce merchandise and
incredible geeky toys picked by myself
Kevin and Jake plus as always a portion
of the proceeds from this box goes to
funding Alzheimer's research you can get
your own by subscribing at the curiosity
box com I'm incredibly proud of this go
check it out and as always thanks for
watching